en el diagrama el segmento de recta ha
de inter seca al segmento b y el
segmento de recta a b es paralelo a d
cuál es la longitud de la 12a al ver el
diagrama parece que el triángulo pequeño
de la izquierda es semejante al
triángulo de la derecha pero no nos
quedemos con la duda y vamos a
demostrarlo para demostrar esto
recordamos que a b es paralelo a de y
para hacer más claro esto voy a extender
estos segmentos y hacer evidente que son
rectas paralelas y que tenemos dos
rectas transversales que intersectan
estas rectas paralelas
estas rectas se extienden en ambas
direcciones y ahora si podemos ver que
esta recta es paralela a esta otra recta
esto nos ayuda a determinar que estos
dos triángulos son semejantes
lo primero que notamos es que este
ángulo es congruente con este otro
ángulo si observamos la recta p como una
transversal a estas dos rectas paralelas
entonces este ángulo es un ángulo
interno alterno que corresponde con este
otro ángulo de acá son
los internos alternos por lo que son
congruentes si esto suena como un idioma
desconocido que no se entiende los
invito a que vean los vídeos que tenemos
sobre ángulos rectas paralelas y
transversales usando el mismo argumento
si observamos la recta ade como una
transversal este otro ángulo es un
ángulo interno alterno al ángulo que
está acá arriba por lo que son
congruentes
el objetivo al hacer todo esto es
demostrar que estos tres ángulos de aquí
son congruentes con estos otros tres
ángulos de acá por lo que estos
triángulos son semejantes esto es útil
porque si dos triángulos son semejantes
entonces la proporción entre las
longitudes de los lados correspondientes
va a ser la misma
por ejemplo la proporción del lado de la
longitud del segmento c
con respecto al lado o segmento d que
mide 7.5 es igual a la proporción del
lado correspondiente en el otro
triángulo el lado c es opuesto al ángulo
verde por lo que en el triángulo pequeño
el lado opuesto al ángulo verde es el
segmento b
que mide 2.1 así que es igual a la
proporción de este lado 2.1 con el lado
que corresponde al lado d
en el otro triángulo el lado de es
opuesto al ángulo azul por lo que le
corresponde el lado b a tenemos que
dividir entre 2.5 a que es igual el lado
c hay varias formas de resolver esto
pero aquí vamos a multiplicar ambos
lados por 7.5 los 7.5 de este lado se
cancelan ya que es igual 7.5 dividido
entre 2.5 bueno 75 entre 25 estrés por
lo que es 7.5 entre 2.5 es igual a 3 la
longitud del segmento c es igual a 2.1
por 3 y el resultado es 6.3 si vemos las
opciones encontramos que este resultado
es la segunda opción nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo